normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we got
this from Business Insider Trump who's
railed against black lives matter for
years now says he'd be very honored to
have its support that's actually phrased
rather poorly he actually said thank you
for your support and so basically you've
got this uh former BLM black lives
matter leader who said the Democratic
party is not for us he says uh he's for
we got this guy Fisher introduced by Fox
as a co-founder of black lives matter
Rhode Island said personally I love the
man I mean how could you not like a real
man how could you not relate to someone
like that Trump then wrote on Truth
social that he had spoken with Fischer
he called a great guys is very honored
to have his and BLM support uh Trump
said before claiming to have done more
for black people than any other
president Lincoln and off disputed
remark he's regularly made in the last
few years now we've got um let let me
see if I have this one is from uh Matt
Walsh where we go uh here we go Matt
Walsh took the Trump BLM situ uh took
the Trump BLM sit situation in no
situation should Trump be thanking a
Marxist terrorist organization if desist
thanked BLM Trump fans would never stop
talking about it ever says when honest
people hear Republican thanking BLM they
should be asking questions about what
the person really stands for completely
disagree Trump is smart it was the smart
play Black lives matter did not endorse
Trump trump is trying to make people
think they did because he's trying to PR
manipulate people he he's sort of saying
black guys love me yeah exactly it's
also misleading in general you know how
there's the bunch of the different
libertarian parties and then there's a
couple of them that're just like super
like say way Wilder stuff and then
people always kind of uh you know they
they'll they'll be like oh the
libertarian part is out of control but
it'll be like a small part of it this is
the same thing this is the one BLM
chapter saying they like Trump the other
one's posting gliders but it's one guy
it's one yeah they're posting the GL
yeah like they're they're very that's
what I mean they a million different
chapters TR Trump knows the media this
is how he gets it because what's going
to happen is some Suburban W wife is
going to be sitting with the other wine
moms and one's going to go did you hear
Black lives matter endorsed Trump what
was that like that means we endorse
Trump well it's going to open the door
for people to be like I guess Trump's
not that bad well they have their Shelf
with like BLM and like a trump with his
face crossed out and they're just like
huh puts it in a bit of a bind and to
Matt Walsh's point that if Dan santis
thanked BLM he'd get roasted maybe but I
don't think by most people and this
shows exactly why desis has been
struggling with it because sis doesn't
understand the dandis campaign doesn't
get people Donald Trump thanking BLM I'm
like wow Trump's winning if Ronda santis
did the same thing like someone from BLM
endorsed Ronda santis and he said thank
you I'd be like very good very very good
of him to embrace those who are
supporting him the fact that they they
view it that way explains exactly why
the San campaign has been slid I think
there's a part of it as the to break an
to make an omelet you got to break a few
eggs and in this case Matt Walsh being
mad at used the egg you know what I mean
and SZ would be afraid to break any of
those eggs
yeah is done though SZ is not going to
amfest and so uh this was something uh
uh Jack was talking about this last
night right pretty sure man I wonder
that they they they it was a
conversation and it ended yeah they
invited him and then he's like I'm not
going to come and it's like you you're
trying to win a primary why aren't you
coming to this massive event with all of
these people I mean Tucker Carlson's
going to be there like basically
everybody's going to be there it's an
opportunity if he showed up we'd all
shake his hand and be like we we you're
the best governor in the country we love
your work instead he's like I'm not
going to do it it's wild I got to
prepare for my debate with some guy
that's not even running yep crazy got a
session with my cobbler those things are
long well uh apparently the rumor is he
bought inserts he bought when he's like
they're they're they're off the off the
rack lii boots yes and so were your
inserts off the rack from you know from
some other store you jammed him in there
but dude come on the guy's wearing high
heels man yeah it's crazy they're Sav
maybe that's why go to mest cuz Charlie
Kirk is like also 100t tall and so if he
stands next to him it'll look kind of
off if he went the craziest like that
you can't like that the rest Tom Cruz
and Vin Diesel and Mark walber man I
guess but they're only I guess find a
picture of that guy beside Nick where
he's not in an Apple box that's why I
think the Sanders won't come on this
show because Tim is fairly tall I'm 5'9
like he could yeah but pbd is tall and
he he actually pulled the boots and
slammed them on the
desk he becomes the president he goes
hey we need like a 15 16 scale Oval
Office we just need to make it slightly
small they put the panel on the front of
the desk in the Oval Office to hide the
wheelchair so it's not the craziest
thing we've ever done oh that's when
they added the panel mhm to hide the
wheelchair my well but the but cuz if
you look at pictures of Kennedy there's
like there's a famous picture of um his
son playing under the desk you can see
it but then the panel but that's because
that's actually a different desk the
original desk it has that secret
compartment with the with the the
writing in it oh yeah so you can track
down the the Declaration of Independence
or the treasure or whatever what was the
treasure in that movie anyway I never
saw it talking about American naal
treasure National talk about like the
greatest movie series of all time oh
that first one was you know what if we
can convince Ron three of them or two if
we can convince Ron to go to amfest and
do a skit about the boots that's really
funny and then he'll just be a rock star
that's it no he
can't that might go not the way he
thinks you guys all saw my boot sketch
and everyone's he can't do it because
the boots are real if are you sure
though oh come on dude but the Wikipedia
says he's anywhere from 5'5 to 5'11 I
heard he's on actual stilts in
interview another person listen there's
a smaller Ronda s there's that video of
him on stage where you can clearly see
his foot the front of the shoe is bent
up there's no foot in there so come on
like there there are there are way too
many news stories breaking down various
photos and they actually even talked to
cobblers who are like oh yeah those are
lifts no question he's
58 cobblers have never been interviewed
this much in their lives dude he was
walking home from the club holding in
his hand but so the point is if it was
not true he could do a sketch and it
would be hilarious he'd show up and then
he he he' choke with the boots on it
wouldn't be a sensitive issue well guess
the make or break moment I'm assuming
it's he would be exposing that he's
wearing high heels if he does the skit
okay he did really sign him up to wear
those high heels for the rest of his
life yeah you're like to die in those
undo those be incredible though if he
debates Trump and then Trump shows up in
his own heels just to further it yes you
really are small huh well right so you
know the point of the heels is basically
to to make him appear taller against
other candidates so if Trump wore like
4in lifts yeah just it make him look
really short and be like I'm wearing the
same boots as Ronnie over here little
Ron they call him I've gotten so much
content out of Ron his Li whoever put
him in those lifts it was the worst move
they ever made I could not have imagined
this would be one of the major political
talking points going into this year I
come on no even car I had no idea how
tall the Howard Dean woohoo there's a
whole bunch of wack
you couldn't have predicted the lifs I
mean come on that's I know I'm saying
the fact that there's a weird moment
where some candidate did something goofy
that's like that's what happens like
Mitt Romney and the dog or whatever I
mean we talked about Trump's hand size
for four years so yeah that's a good
point they things do get overanalyzed
that's so weird like his hands they made
up that thing about his hands it's just
like does that work for people who don't
like Trump they did it for Napoleon they
said he was short they different
measurements well no that's that's
because the Imperial guards are tall and
so people would often compare him in in
in paintings to tall Imperial guards oh
he must have been short and he wasn't
and now we talk about King Charles's
hands right like the
English those are crazy hands those are
something going on there yeah those are
weird Sasha's hands I just I get small
places on the island someone someone
comes to me and they're like uh Donald
Trump wants to fire a bunch of people he
wants to secure our borders bring back
manufacturing and Foreign Wars and I'm
like oh okay and then the left goes
Grump you mean with little hands and I'm
like I I I don't understand like is that
an argument am I I don't get it it was
to them that was very clever those like
plastic little hands that people used to
wear I used to see those on Tik Tok all
the time like the T yeah did did he
accidentally make something cool by
hands does it turn out he has just big
hands or normal hands or something he
probably has normal hands and someone
took a shot at his hands and then he
gets super defensive about stuff like
he'll so he goes I got normal hands
totally like and then he makes all thing
I don't know and then the most normal
and probably was like did a couple
sketches about the hands and then I
don't know just the hands become a thing
I just no one's talking about the hands
now with the boots and equation guys in
a few minutes the debate with desandis
and Newsome is going to start and I just
I honestly I cannot care you know I I I
part of me is like there's this news
thing happening and like maybe we should
check it out and I'm just like pants
lifts but nothing matters the only thing
that matters is something about the
boots the reality is oh do you think do
you think that they're not going to push
uh Gavin Nome to become the nominee they
are I think they are so that's what this
is is like take a look at yeah yeah like
just like seeing how he PS against the
Santa like they're both down they Crouch
they're about The Gunshot has gone off
and then they just take off running and
this is it this is the moment when the
run just starts and this is airing on
Fox only I don't I guess because it's um
Sean Spicer show and then he just agreed
to host SE Spicer has a show on Fox now
they're trying to appeal no Hannity
Hannity so they're trying to appeal Nome
to the right wing now they want the
conservatives to See's a good gas
honestly you if you uh if you find
yourself listening to Newsome he can
convince people of things man he is a
good speaker yeah so what's going to
happen because Biden doesn't want to
before you listen to new for an hour
you're like maybe California is crushing
it thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at
timcast.net
am